all right so good morning everyone I'm
Alex boots a director of the bd2k
centers Coordination Center and so this
morning we had the pleasure of having
dr. xiaoming Howe a professor at Georgia
Tech University at the Stewart school of
industrial systems in engineering
research encompasses a number of areas
including statistical theory this
statistical computing and as such its
relation to data sciences his work
coverage areas related to sparse
representations wavelets and statistical
problems in detectability he's a fellow
of the American Statistical Association
and today he'll be talking to us about
methods for distributed optimization and
learning an issue that is certainly
pertinent to biomedical big data and
then often are data that cannot be
centralized for any number of reasons
he'll be discussing some contemporary
methods for distributed statistical
computation and their applications
including in healthcare dr. ho it's
great to have you speaking with us this
morning and I'm looking forward to
hearing more about this work the floor
is yours thank you Alex and I would like
to start with the thanking crystal and
Alex for setting this off and does Alex
ed I'm today I'm going to talk about
computational and still efficient just
give me a second I cannot see all the
slides that I have on my screen oh it's
fine I'm going to talk about a
computational and specific efficient the
inference with theoretical guarantee and
in particular I probably say that maybe
because of my background this particular
presentation is is more focused on the
statistical aspect of this problem but I
would also mention in the computational
aspect of this problem as well
you
the agenda for today I'll start with the
motivation and give a brief survey of a
state of art offer the message along
this line of a distributed inference I
may have to mention that this is not
intended to be comprehensive is a very
very active area with a lot of new ideas
are coming other you know intensive your
tastes I probably can only be
selectively emphasizing the type of the
problem that I'll be focusing on and in
particular in the third part I'll talk
about one of our homework which is a
particular strategy to make a
distributed algorithm work in the
optimal way in the statistical sense and
in the mean time we try to keep the
computational and the communication
costs down and we're going to present
some simulations to validate or
theoretical results and they'll finish
with some conclude conclusion remarks
and also talk about some potential
future work so I'm going to start with
the motivation and this slide is a
number of English slides
it's my beer already on outdated but on
the other hand is if the problem becomes
more important more evident in the
current contemporary society I'll still
go over this is this information which
is close information I listed here so
one example is that we're now in the era
of a big data II some social media
websites so for example the Twitter comp
and they Pro many years ago they've
already produced seven terabytes of data
daily and now they can only be higher
and another example is six years ago on
a particular day of Black Friday a
within four hours
the warmer has already handled the 10
million cash register enter transactions
and so the nearly 5,000 items per second
and I'm pretty sure they're nowadays
this number can only be increased and
then also moremore that
the practice industry and many important
applications that they have become
decentralized so here I gave my example
and I probably gave more examples a
little bit later doing us a search
engine company they may have a lot of
data and this is impossible to stay as
far all the data on the same platform or
in the same location so the data will be
at the distributed fashion but in the
meantime they may want to solve a some
some problem at the global scale so how
to solve a global problem with
distributed data that's what we are
going to talk about in the next 40
minutes
and as I said this particular
presentation is probably focusing on the
inference aspect of this problem so here
I'm going to present the general
framework II so the the culture on the
current slide what you see is the
traditional diagram that we presented in
the statistical literature so for
example so here is the explanation of
the diagram we always assume that there
is a distribution and this distribution
may be governed by some a set of
parameters and we observe data and a lot
of time we assuming that the lost data
are independent and tactically say
sampled from the distribution and the
task of us the division is to come up
with something called estimator which is
basically a function of the data and
this estimator is supposed to have some
capability to to infer the true value of
the parameter and a lot of us that is
the literature is based on this a
framework and all the master has been
developed such as the Bayesian approach
the maximum likelihood estimation and
many more and also a lot of a serum has
been developed so for example under
certain conditions we can show that the
maximum likelihood estimate is the most
efficient estimator and also we can also
derive things like like the asymptotic
distribution of this estimators so based
on that we can compare different
possible estimators and and it gives for
example the minimax rage of offer those
estimators under certain conditions so a
lot of existing standard statistical
literature is based on this this
framework and now if we are talking
about a distributed inference the the
framework can be illustrated by this
diagram which is a
still have a distribution and we
assuming that this distribution is
governed by a particular set of values
of the parameter and we also have data
but this data they are not they are not
in a centralized in a central location
anymore
so they are spread out at a different
station or location or in different
platforms and moreover these data will
be very expensive or impossible to
transfer them to our central location
and on the other hand we still have this
estimation problem which is how can we
come up with an estimator such that this
estimator is some sense doing a good
inference work towards the N lying value
of the parameter and in particular how
is due on duplicate the Cerreto result
that we can do in the sense in the in
the previous of framework and the
additional difficulty is that when we
construct those estimators we may not
make the assumption that we have
accessed through all the data or at
least we the estimator when we could
generate the estimator we cannot assume
that we can have access to all the data
simultaneously we may have indirect
access to the data but we don't have
direct access to all of them so this is
a the framework that we are going to
based on and the method that will be
developed is the for the distributed
inference
and well the continuing only motivation
why do we want to do the distributed
inference so first of all there will be
scenarios that centralize the method is
no longer possible to implement and
another motivation is that nowadays the
speed of local processors can be solved
in solvent time faster than the read of
the data transmission in a contemporary
network so for example in a regular CPU
or GPU the clock speed has already
reached the gigabytes which in series
says that we can carry out billions of
computations per second on the other
hand most of the network the the network
that we can have access to
we probably transmit at a megabytes
which means that they can transmit the
millions of bits of data per second so
the difference between the processing
and the transmission is a is basically
one where one versus the thousand so
that's why the local processing speed
can be much faster than the speed of
transmit data transmission and also it
is evidently advantageous to develop a
communication efficient distributed up
methods instead of transmitted
transmitting data to a central location
and they apply a one location based
estimator
and here is a some additional examples
which motivate the distributed inference
so for example the as I mentioned before
a web search engine company they may
have a data in different platforms and
on the other hand they may come up with
the move on to do some global model in
order to carry out some inference tasks
and in order to do so they need to do
the distributed or inference and we may
also have some international
organizations they have the data stored
all over the world and in the meantime
they want to build up us on a global
model so in that case they meet is a
well-needed distributed inference we
also could have a supply chain companies
they may process goods which will be
transmitted into many locations and we
were supplied by thousands of the
suppliers and not all the suppliers may
be willing to share their company
information and if they want through
still build up with some model for for
example for forecasting or diagnosis
they may want to apply some distributed
the inference technology and this also
may apply to the government make apply
to for example in the public health
surveillance for example the same Center
for Disease Control and Prevention's
they may have a lot of data which
another may not be easy to share across
the locations but in the mean time they
probably want to build up a summer
global model based on all the
distributed data and probably one more
example is the in the hospital hospital
are very sensitive about privacy they
may not even want to share the data at
all but then the question will be
without sharing data is it still
possible to build a model based on multi
hospitals in in order to do that we also
need to solve the problem of a
distributed inference and of course
there are many other situations that the
distribute inference is necessary and
I'm going to start with a review it
turns out that I'm going to
reveal something which is not happening
on the topic of a distributed inference
instead it happens in the computational
mathematics a lot of time under the
terminology distributed the optimization
or or some other name so the idea is
that there is there is a minimize this
optimization problem it could be a
minimization problem or maximization
problem may be have the some constraints
and if I solve the original problem can
be impossible or very expensive and then
the idea is how to split the problem
into some smaller problems and solve
them potentially in a parallel fashion
so that way not only so each subproblem
becomes easy to solve and then they
aggregate all the solutions into a
global solution so the advantage is that
not only they can paralyze the beasts of
the earth tourism and it can so they can
also increase the size of the problem we
can solve and also increase the speed to
find the solution one my representative
work is the probably the alternating
direct direction method of multiplies
all rhythms which is also called a DMM
and after the a DMM a lot of work has
also been introduced I only give a a few
examples as a matter of fact if we
search the references offer the ad mmm
book chapter you'll find solvents or can
tens of thousands of papers afterwards
all about this topic so the example I
give is that the sector Y is the second
bullet which is paralyzed the stochastic
gradient descent method for empirical
risk minimization and another one I give
is distributed approximate Newton type
method and as I mentioned there are a
lot more development and this is a more
on the numerical aspect and as I said
this particular presentation I probably
would have focused on the statistical
property instead of
talking about the different numerical
techniques that can be applied to the
distributed inference and one particular
piece of work I would like to mention is
that is this is a paper by Becky fan at
all and it was published in 2015
archive and now I believe it has been a
paper up here the annals of statistics
and they propose the following framework
for the distributed inference that is in
the first column so each location they
generate the best their best possible
estimator and a lot of time this is a
probably M estimator so I'll give more
details about what this could be a
little bit later and then they apply a
statistical technique which is called
the biasing they and the biasing they're
they're the the T estimator will have
some better statistical property and and
then enter for for each row this is done
at the location level and therefore the
at a global level what they do is they
take a same cinco average of all the
local estimators to generate their
global estimator and afterwards they are
probably one more step which is to do
some kind of a threshold in to to the
generated estimator so threshold a means
that if the global estimator in this
block is a high dimensional vector and
if the entry of a vector is close to
zero then set it to be zero and if it's
a far away from zero then do some kind
of threshold in with which it could be
either keep the value of all reduce a
barrier in absolute value a little bit
and then they prove that the the final
estimator have many nice theoretical
properties and I'll give you a simple
example a little bit later and
and a lot of this to this presentation
I'm going to talk about one particular
one particular way to solve the for to
do the distributive inference so the for
today I'm going to focus on the method
that they use something which is called
an estimator this call this is a general
framework called M estimation and then
what is M estimation so the end
estimation is it can be described by the
first equation or these slides so what
it is is that it introduced some some
function which is denoted by M and this
function is a function of theta which is
denoted by X in this equation and as
well as the parameter which is the data
in this in this expression so M is a
function of both data and the parameter
and and then we take the sum of those M
estimations and the X is the represent
all the data point and this si represent
the particular location the ice location
so X belongs to s I meaning that we are
taking the summation of this M function
but those data sets they all belongs
through one particular location which is
the ice location and this total sum
divided by the cardinality of the
numbers of elements in this si set so
this is the average of this M function
so this will be called the M function
but this is a 40 ice location and the M
estimator what it what it is is that I
would pick the number for the theta and
theta belongs to the domain where this
theta should reside and I pick the value
of the theta which maximize this M
function and the D the D Maximizer is
the is a quality M estimator and in this
framework so for example if I choose the
m to be the log likelihood function then
basically this ad
estimation will give me the maximum
likelihood estimation
so the maximal actual estimation is a
special case of this M estimation and
now if I want to find the global global
optimal a global M estimator the in
theory what I need to do is to calculate
the total sum of those local M functions
but the calculating this total sum of
the local M functions requiring access
to all the all the data set which is
considered impossible in the distributed
inference because in the distributed
inference we cannot make the assumption
that we have access to all the data
points
you
so as I said before the but on the other
hand is this a global M estimation also
give us a benchmark so we could denote
if we can hypothetically transmit all
the data to a central position and then
we can apply this M estimation to come
up with estimates and this estimator
will be the global M estimator and we
can and this estimator is in some sense
optimal because M estimation is know in
statistics under certain conditions they
are the best possible estimator that can
be generated in in those scenario and so
so when we generate a estimator in the
distributed fashion one question we may
ask is that how does this a distributed
estimator compare through this this idea
idealistic a global estimator and the VI
it's a global estimator by the way is
considered an infeasible in the
distributed framework so one possible
way which will be the starting point of
our distributed inference is the
following so recall that mi is the local
empirical criteria function on the m's
location or the MS machine and recall
that it is defined as the summation of
these m functions which is a function of
the data in the parameter and also
recall that a local estimator can be
obtained by just locally maximize the
this empirical criteria function so we
get a local estimator and then one way
to come up with the global estimator is
that every location well then send their
local estimator through the central
location and then the central location
simply take an average and this is an
estimator which is called a cinco
averaging estimator and was introduced
in a paper in 2013 and for this paper
there's already some nice theoretical
property can be derived under certain
condition the Cinco averaging estimator
is already good in many sense and on the
other hand obviously there's a room to
improve this kind of estimator it's a
sink very simple estimator and later in
the next session we are going to talk
about how we can improve this estimators
and which kind of improvement we can
obtain so to talk about the enhancement
for the previous estimator I'm going to
talk about statistical idea and in
particular we're going to call our
master a one-step distributed estimator
and we are going to show that it achieve
stronger Oracle SN Kotik opportunity in
the statistical theory and also that it
does not significantly increase the
demand for computing and and the
communication so let me first talk about
the statistical technique which is
called one step approach so the general
idea of the web step approach is first
one finds a consistent but possibly in
efficient estimator so here consistent
in the statistical sense means that if
the sample size goes to infinity then
this estimator would converge to the
ground choose the ground the true value
of the parameter and inefficient means
that the convergence rate of this
estimator is not necessarily the best
possible rate that we have obtained or
we can obtain the according to the
statistical theory and and then one step
approach main idea is to do one step
Newton was scoring iteration and I'll
give more details about what doc do I
mean by when stack of Newton or scoring
iteration and then we end up with a new
estimator and this new estimator will be
called a one step estimator and it turns
out that in statistic it's interesting
to find out that for this kind of
approach you can make
the potentially in efficient estimator
to become an efficient estimator in the
sense that we know in statistics a lot
of sense in many situations we can show
that maximum likelihood estimator is the
efficient estimator because it achieves
an Fisher information which is a lower
bound of the asymptotic variance and we
can show that if we adopt this one step
approach then a potentially inefficient
estimator we could we can make them to
become an efficient estimator okay so
here is a the mathematical definition of
the one step estimator so in the one
step estimator recall in the previously
we talked about this a simple average
estimator and what this is a simple
recall this a simple average estimator
is that each location generates their
local M estimator and then it sends
their local estimator to the central
location and then at the central
location I just simply take the average
of the loss the local M estimator so
they'll be my synchro estimator and the
one-step estimator is doing the
following which is I suppose I have
access to the so this m dot is a
gradient of the global empirical
criterion function and then this is
double dots of M is the the second
derivative which will be the Hessian of
the global in critical criteria function
now the the the new thing it Roxann it
update is the following so I if I can
calculate the gradient add to the simple
average estimator and if I can also
calculate to the Haitian and to the
Cinco average estimator I'll take the
inverse of this Hessian multiplied with
this a gradient which is basically an
a-minus and this is a one-step of a
Newton update and add it to the simple
estimator and now I have this new
estimator and then suddenly I can show
that this new estimator if this is a
simple estimator theta 0 is inefficient
on a lot of conditions I can show that
at
this new estimators and become efficient
so here is the detailed step in our
proposed estimator so is so again we
start with a start from each location in
England each location when calculate the
Maximizer of their local empirical
active in critical criteria criteria
function and this is generally the local
M estimator and then at each location
sends their estimator to the central
location and at the central location we
calculate the the synchro average
estimator and this is our starting point
and then the central location broadcast
this single estimator to all the
locations that had each location they
compute the gradient of their empirical
criterion function and also the
calculated Hessian of their in critical
criteria function but add to the episode
absolute at where the the simple average
estimator is and then they send this a
local gradient and the localization
through the central location at the
central location it turns out that the
the gradient the gradient and hey cm
they're additive in the sense that the
global gradient is actually the can be
computed as the average of those local
gradients and the global vision can be
computed as the average of the local
Haitians and this is due to the
construction of this empirical criteria
functions they are additive and so to so
this way after the central location we
can compute to the legree diem and hey
CN and then we can apply the prick the
fo mentioned the Newton update step F
and then we can obtain to the Wednesday
of estimator and then this is the
estimator we proposed to use in the
next I'm going to talk about the theory
that can be pro can be derived under the
Buddha the the estimator that we have
adjusted derived so it turns out that
well the next few slides and probably
will be more towards the statistical
theory so there are some general
assumptions that we need to make in
order to establish in the results but
those assumptions are very generic
assumptions and in most of most of them
appear in the papers that that we have
typically seen in the literature so for
example we are assuming that the
parameter space is a compact and the
convex set and the reason is we most of
time when we talk about when we consider
the parameter space they are financial
so we will not consider the unbounded of
parameter space because most of the time
we have a pretty good idea about what
what would it be the value of those of
parameters we also make the assumption
that the Hessian of the population
criteria function so this is the
expected value of the empirical criteria
function we assuming it is a non
singular matrix which means that the
Hessian is negative definite and there's
also exists it exists the lambda which
such that the minus lambda is the upper
bound of the eigen values of the ACM
matrix this condition particular
condition may be loosened but Emperor in
this talk when not going further in this
direction it might be some interesting
future work - all may be has already
been done by loosened this particular
condition for the particular measure we
are taught so we found that we need to
introduce some some kind of strong
smoothness to conditions in order to
obtain our theoretical results these are
illustrated on this slide that basically
means that we assuming the gradient of
the empirical function has to some fine
other final final moments and also for
the ASEAN has some finite high order
moments and again it'll be it is
possible to weaken those conditions but
in our current work we adopted just in
order to get the result that we
presented during the next few slides and
suppose we other support all those
assumptions are taken then we can show
that the one step estimator it actually
enjoys the so-called Oracle asymptotic
property and so so so many explain what
do I mean by the Oracle asymptotic
property so we can show that for Sigma
which is a matrix that is defining this
way we can place a show and and so the
render and if the numbers of machines is
no more than the square root of capital
N and here the capital n is the is the
total numbers of observations and in
this particular serum will probably us
assume that all that the date the data
size at different locations they are red
they're roughly the same or you could
close to each other and the total
numbers of location is at the square
root N and the total sample size is the
total numbers of location is no more
than square root of n then we so with
this we can show that that if we adopt
this one-step estimator and if this is
Theta 0 indicating the ground truth
which means that that is the true value
of the parameter then we could be used
in the data generation then this first
of all the one-step estimator converged
to the ground truth and also in terms of
the convergence rate we can show that
this convergence in distribution this
essentially means even like a
convergence in distribution is true so
basically the difference of with the one
step estimator and the ground choose
scaled by root n which is n is the
sample
the sample size the guessing tactically
has this a normal distribution and the
variance and covariance of this
asymptotic normal is given by the Sigma
which have this which has a formula that
is expressed above so so so we can
establish this theorem which basic
characterize how efficient estimator can
be and this kind of result is also well
known in the centralized case also in
the so so with deriving this kind of a
result so that we can compare all
distributed estimator with those with
those idealistic centralized method and
can do a meaningful comparison but
looking at the azan Kotik distributions
that you can achieve
we based on the previous one but we can
also derive the upper bound for the mean
square error this is we derive this
mostly because in the literature some
people use the upper bound of the square
arrow to evaluate their logarithm so we
thought that we should derive similar
things for the purpose of comparison but
this may also be viewed as a direct
result of the previous theory
you
and in particular if we choose a
criteria function to be the
log-likelihood function so that is if
this criteria function is the
log-likelihood function where the f is a
density function and then log of density
function becomes a log likelihood
function then we can show that at the
end the one step estimator has the same
asymptotic property does the ML the
maximum I could estimator and this
maximum likelihood estimator is based on
the assumption that all the data have
been transferred to the central location
and there is no distributed inference
involved and so the estimator is the
most idealistic estimator in that case
so this corollary describe this this
fact so the the the one step estimator
is consistent and asymptotically
efficient estimator because it it
converged to the ground truth according
by the this say this the first the
convergence result says that the
converging to the ground truth and
second one being said the asymptotic
distribution of the difference scaled by
root n is asking talking normal and in
particular this the the variance and
covariance is the Fisher information
lower bound for the asymptotic variance
that could be achieved even when the
data are not distributed the data are
located in the central location so that
shows that even though it is a
distributed inference we can do like a
talk to this of one step approach we can
do as well as all the data were present
at the one location and we could also
extend this result to the scenario well
oh yes
assuming that the communication is not a
reliable also some some information
could be lost in the transmission so the
way to deal with that is that we still
can consider a simple average but this
time we introduce a parameter this is AI
and AI can only become a p 0 or 1 so if
it is equal to 1 if
communication is successful so that the
central location obtained the
information from the ice location and
otherwise it is equal to zero so then
basically this is going to be the
average this is going to be the average
estimator for all the after all the
successful communications and this will
be the corresponding one-step estimator
for those based on those locations which
can successfully transmit data to the
central location and and we can show
similar results even with under the
consideration that there could be
communication failure the previous
established result is also true in the
in this scenario so and and this is a
this is the comparable theoretical
result that can obtain in this scenario
and next I'm going to show some
simulation to validate all theoretical
results so we have we talked about we in
this presentation we focus more on the
statistical property and so for that we
are going to consider the following
competitors why is the simple average
estimator which I mentioned earlier
and then next one will be our estimate
of proposed estimator which we call it a
one-step estimator and we are also going
to use a benchmark which is a
centralized and estimator so that means
that all the data have been transferred
to one location and we use the best of
possible static approach which is it
could be the maximum likely estimate
approach to find that the estimator and
the third one is idealistic and may not
be and is considered impossible in the
distributed inference setting and we
also consider one more in the existing
literature so in particular in John 2013
which I people
becomes a paper published in the Journal
of machine learning research they also
introduce a recent resample average
averaging estimator which is the main
ideas of the introduce a bootstrapper
type of estimator and the purpose is to
do the to reduce the bias in the
original estimator so this way it could
improve the original estimator
so in in our first experiment given that
a logistic regression has been so widely
used in in application so for example
customer segmentation crappy risky risk
analysis and so on so we decide to do
the first experiment do the first
assimilation through the logistic
regression so recall that in the
logistic regression we have a binary
response and the parameter of this The
Associated ballooning distribution is P
and P P depends on the covariance which
X is the covariance a set of covariance
and plus the parameter theta and the so
theta is unknown and X is a these are
the predictors of covariates they are
available and we can also observe the
binary observation which is why so the
purpose is to estimate the value of the
parameter theta in this framework and we
consider we did the following comparison
so this is a logistic regression
framework we we generate those data so
because it is a simulated data we know
the ground choose and we compare
different messer why is the centralized
method which means that this is a
measure that all the data available I
can calculate the likelihood function at
the set the field a global likelihood
function and then maximize it together
the MLE solution maximum like an
estimator and I can also use the simple
average estimator which is which is in
the I have total numbers of observations
and then I divide them into the certain
number into certain numbers of machines
and then at each machinery called
average estimator is that each machine
calculates a local estimator and then
globally they take the average of those
local estimators and now we propose is a
one-step approach and in this figure
what you see is that the the horizontal
axis is the
numbers of machines and the vertical
line is a mean square error which is
every time using each of this measure we
can come up with estimates of the
parameter theta and in the mean time
because we generate those data so we
also know the ground truth so we
calculated the squared error sum of the
squared error in that case we repeat
this experiment for 50 times to to
obtain the average of this a mean
squared error also so these are the
numbers which were plotted over here and
as you can see that if I use the average
as a simple average estimator when the
numbers of if you if we all start with a
zero machine it probably doesn't matter
because they all end up with the same
one machine global estimator global any
estimator anyway so so the the perform
the same but as the numbers of machines
increase then the mean square error for
the simple average become increase as
the numbers of machines are go becomes
bigger but if we look at well the the
centralized it will stay horizontal
because the centralized master is not
affected by the numbers of machines and
we put it here just as a benchmark and
if you look at the all one step measured
we see that there is almost exactly the
same as the as the decentralized the
measured so and also in our theory we
predict that if we use a one-step method
as in contact distribution wise it will
be similar to the to the ideal list
idealistic central method also so this
kind of a confirmed what we proved in
our theory and this in this figure which
shows the data to be twenty dimensional
and then we decide to do another
experiment and in this experiment with
data and becomes a hundred dimensional
so it becomes a higher dimensional data
and in this particular example we found
that so again the for the centralized
one
the the mean square error is not going
to change much so so so all Messrs and
become slightly worse because of the
increase of the dimensionality so become
so so the look this the speed a
converged through the optimum will be
slower than the global one so so become
a little bit worse but again it's much
better than a simple average estimator
the next one we consider is a for the
beta distribution in this in this a beta
distribution we have a parameter alpha
and a beta and we observe the value
which is sampled from this beta
distribution and then the question is
how do we estimate the parameters in
this scenario and in this particular
case we we also compare so this time we
compare we're adding the resampling
approach that we mentioned earlier and
again in this case we in the horizontal
one is the numbers of machines and
vertical one is the mean squared arrow
and we can see that all mastered is
pretty comparable to the two all measure
which is a one step it's pretty
comparable to the to the centralized
messer which is predicted by the seer
and a neat and this is the highest why
is the the simple average estimator and
the middle one is the one enhance the
binary sampling so in very simply
improve but don't seem to improve don't
seem to improve to the degree that
there's other good ones that matter and
so the the right one is a zoom inversion
offer of this one which is so in the in
the left one the the y-axis the range on
the y axis is from one to 0.9 now on the
right figure the the range of the y axis
becomes zero to two 3.3333 times 1,000
so so we reduce a range on the y-axis in
order to see the details in in this part
of the graph
you
and we also did another experiment in
the case when we assuming that there's a
failure in the communication and we get
a pretty much as similar results but for
the interest of time I probably will
skip skip this slide and also we did a
comparison in terms of the decrease of
the mean square error as a function of
the numbers of locations all the numbers
of machines and this figure shows that
all one step at measured has a nearly
the same convergence rate a same optimal
rate as a centralized messer why the
other measure they probably they're
slightly higher in turn slightly high in
terms of Euler the convergence rate and
in this talk I focus on the distributed
inference and in particular I focus on
the the parametric model framework and
the messer there is a focused on the M
based estimation and there are many
other problems that we may need to solve
in the distributed fashion so for
example we may want to do the
distributed the principle control
analysis we may want to do a distributed
support vector machines we may want to
do a distributed effect matrix
factorization for me we may also want to
do distributed way of doing the matrix
completion all maybe a distributed
version of neural networks but I'm not
going to talk about that in this
particular presentation and another
point I want to make is that it turns
out that at least in the framework of a
parametric model estimation the
asymptotic the Oracle asymptotic of
humanity is achievable even under the
distributed fashion
so asymptotic optimality means that
there are optimal statistical result
that could be obtained in the
centralized diversion and in the
distributed problem is things like a
similar of humanity optimality result
came all identical humanity can be
achieved so we talk about distributed
estimators and in particular I mentioned
this a one step based approach which is
the wrongful recent work we did a static
analysis on this new method and use the
simulations to validate the theoretical
prediction and we mentioned the
potential applications of this offer
cost an answer and I'll also mention
that it turns out ISM there I didn't
give a complete survey but there are
many other different approaches has been
proposed so for example recently I read
just a paper talking about how to use
the surrogates likelihood based method
to solve this type of the problem which
is very interesting and if you want to
know more about what I talked about
today we have an online article so this
is the information about the online
article so we are still doing the
revision so hopefully it will be
accepted by a journal and and finally I
want to thank you for your attention and
I'll stop here for today
great thank you dr. ho for this
wonderful talk we have some time for
questions we actually have a relatively
following group today but I thought two
questions for you
one is you first mentioned for instance
distributed or a need for something like
a distributed approach to PCA could you
first comment on that and whether you
have seen any particular approaches to
being able to do distributed
dimensionality reduction personally um I
I saw several papers uh two or three
years ago talking about the distributed
PCA but
honestly uh I don't remember much about
the details so yes there are some paper
or talking about distributed PCA oh okay
no the name but I don't remember much
details though because it's not a
particular problem I've been spending
time on so I know their existence okay
maybe so the second question is often
when I've seen works in this area at
least in the distributed inference and
certainly distributed machine learning
the approaches obviously have a strong
statistical foundation as you went
through today but they're often limited
to linear techniques and less so to some
of the more nonlinear types of
estimation that that we would like to
consider in some domain can you comment
on that yeah this is a great question
I think because of the distributed the
inference and and the associate
technique it was a buzz I I became aware
of this problem maybe five six years ago
so it's a relatively new topic and I
think the the the theory is growing so
one obvious starting point is to look at
the parametric framework because it then
becomes just a lot of available
technique so it's a really easy to
derive the asymptotic results on the
other hand it is a it is absolutely
correct that there are many other
machine learning based measure and not
necessarily belongs to this framework of
a parametric so I think it is a it is a
either ongoing work or a lot of things
has already been done but nevertheless
it's a it's a promising research
direction for field which you look
growing B so for example I know there
are some work B so far I talked about it
is that this is like I kind of
simplified it in a way that we talk
about a linear regression
so that it can do the D biasing and I
ate the every change simple averaging
can work well I also know that this can
be in some way extended to the nonlinear
situation so for example I've seen
people talking about a semi parametric
model all generalized linear model so in
that way that if you can if you're
willing to so in the linear regression
we basically assuming that it's a
lenient dependency in the in the
framework of a semi parametric or
regression or all in for example
generalized linear regression if we can
make some assumption about the link
function for example the link function
may belongs to the exponential family
then the things like that that I talked
about today they can be extended in
their way to those problems so so so so
then this is a one way to go beyond the
diya the linear model or all the
completely parametric setting and of
course they may not necessarily solve
all the interesting problems some of
this problem can be fundamentally
different from the model that I talked
about the the framework that I talked
about today so so I think the so in
general this this I think the this
question point out that in needs and
more research in this area all right
quickly here um so one question is um so
you proposes one step estimator will it
eventually be compared to the surrogate
likelihood estimator that's mentioned in
the gasset paper
oh I'm sorry can you repeat that
question again so will your proposed
one-step estimator eventually be
compared to the surrogate likelihood
estimator that is seen in the Journal of
the American Statistical Association
paper well this is actually we actually
only recently became aware of that that
work so it's a it's a work on progress
okay and and that's sure it'll be
interesting to compare but I am in that
a well I actually I'm not sure but
there's a possibility that what we are
doing can be framed as a special case in
in the in the in the in the setting of a
surrogate likelihood but I don't know
that for sure
okay thank you again so much for this
great talk and one here thank you Alex